we talk about um stammers
and ramblers you have a chapter on that
yeah i talk about stammerers and
ramblers from a perspective of when
you're doing interviews
there are people who are so quick to
give you an answer because they want to
help you that they give you a third of
what it is you need to hear
they say um
you know hey listen uh yesterday jeff
and i went to that
well here's what here's what happened we
all went to the to this place
and then the guy said wait a minute no
let me tell you how this works
and it's because they're trying to
please you by giving you an immediate
answer
um or there are people who just kind of
fly all over the place and give you
a three-minute long answer to every
question
if you want somebody to be focused and
you want to handle a stabler
a a stammer or a rambler what you do is
you say listen i'm afraid i don't wanna
i don't want
our voices to overlap because we have to
be able to edit this
so i'm going to ask you the question
just mentally just give yourself like a
count of three
and then answer my question that way we
don't have to worry about my voice
getting over yours
you would be amazed at what three to
five seconds will do for the way a
person thinks
it's like when you're buffering a video
it's just it takes a little bit of time
to get it
to get ahead of what's playing and then
all of a sudden you start getting
reasonable well thought out responses
they don't stammer they don't ramble
and you get much better content in the
end from them
that's great and what about people that
are
too on for the camera and you need them
to be in that resting state
i very rarely tell anyone to be less
energetic
in an interview there are some people
who are
really putting it on
and those you have to reel back a little
bit and say like listen you know just
i'm just asking you a question but most
of the time your real problem is getting
people to sound like they're passionate
about something that happened two weeks
ago
it's like explain how the situation
happened to me well we went to the
restaurant and then we did this and
that well first of all don't look at the
floor look at me and then just like
you were excited then like this this
really meant a lot to you and try to
figure out how to get them into that
moment so they're talking about it as if
it's
fresh in the memory and you
just just give them a little bit of
energy and let them know
when they're slacking and when they're
down because most people want to look
good on camera
i always tell them i'm like you're going
to look very low energy and we'll
probably have to come back and ask you
again
you know if the content doesn't work out
well
you